[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en directo américa ya está conmigo en el
estudio daniela blandón danny bienvenida
feliz miércoles vamos a comenzar
hablando precisamente de brasil como
estamos viendo en esa noticia de la moda
el super reciclaje pero hablemos de los
empleos que se están recuperando en este
país y también en chile hola rabón muy
buenos días pues interesantes ahora
vamos a para hacer para mí que estamos
contra el consumismo ahora así es y
señora hablemos ahora de desempleo
porque las oficinas de estadísticas de
este par de países brasil y chile dieron
a conocer sus más recientes datos en el
caso de chile la tasa de desocupación
bajó el 8.1 por ciento en octubre
es un buen descenso si se compara con el
mismo mes del año pasado cuando repuntó
al 11,6 por ciento de hecho raúl es la
menor cifra desde la llegada de la
pandemia al país en marzo de 2020 y
también es el sexto mes de descenso
consecutivo en el último trimestre en
este país se crearon 111 mil plazas
laborales y ya se han recuperado más de
1,3 millones de puestos de trabajo es
decir el 70 por ciento de lo que se
había perdido ahora vamos a brasil en
donde la cifra corresponde al tercer
trimestre y se evidencia asimismo que el
desempleo ya no es del 15% casi sino del
12 3% en este país hay 13,5 millones de
personas sin trabajo en los primeros 10
meses del año sin embargo se han
generado más de 2,6 millones de puestos
a medida pues que se va recuperando la
economía danny y todo el mundo va a
pensar que la cia donde díaz la más cara
del mundo y otra vez fui a la farmacia
me compré un chicle un helado y un
parche para la espalda que me dolía y
eso fueron como 100 mil pesos
colombianos que son más o menos 30
dólares buena imagínense año pareció muy
caro porque fue una pues lo tenían a
mano ni siquiera tiene una bolsa pero
ahora le pregunto objetivamente a llenar
cuál es la ciudad más cara del mundo
bueno la ciudad más cara es tel aviv y
esto no lo digo yo lo dice the economist
tel aviv en israel que por primera vez
lidera este ranking esta ciudad israelí
subió este año cinco peldaños y se ubicó
primera por encima incluso de países o
de ciudades como parís y singapur que
comparten el segundo puesto
zurich en suiza hong kong por el lado
del continente americano raúl es tan
nueva york en el sexto puesto y los
ángeles en el noveno dan y le pregunto
entonces en qué se basa esta revista
para hacer este ranking imagino que no
comí de la farmacia no por supuesto que
no mire ellos elaboran un índice de
costo de vida mundial en el que comparan
los precios en dólares estadounidenses
de los bienes y servicios de 173
ciudades y en israel tuvo en cuenta su
inflación vertiginosa y la fortaleza de
su moneda local frente al dólar el
check-in pues además hay que decir que
en este dato de inflación promedio no
incluyen a cuatro ciudades con tasas
excepcionalmente altas como son caracas
en venezuela usted lo sabe damasco en
siria buenos aires en argentina y
teherán en irán aunque éstas sí están
incluidas en el ranking de hecho en la
capital israelí subió del puesto 79 al
20 perdón iraní subió del puesto 79 al
29 teherán y la más barata deviene cuál
es cuál es daniela damasco y hablando de
caracas y es verdad es a mi hermana que
aquí acaba de ir mi hijo que todo está
como si estuviera en miami además todo
organizado ahora hablemos de pago de
deudas porque argentina va a ser otro
pago al fondo monetario internacional
bueno recordemos que este país tiene un
crédito con el fondo monetario
internacional por 56 mil millones de
dólares que adquirió el ex presidente
mauricio macri finalmente de ese total
se entregaron sólo 44 mil millones de
dólares y el gobierno de alberto
fernández está tratando de renegociar
los intereses y el plazo de esa enorme
deuda la secretaria de relaciones
económicas dijo que mientras continúan
las conversaciones prevén hacer un pago
en diciembre próximo por 1.880 millones
de dólares y el que hagan estas
negociaciones ahora daniela pues el
gobierno tiene previsto enviar en
diciembre un proyecto al parlamento con
el avance que tenga de estas
negociaciones pero no han sido fáciles
del fondo monetario debería recibir unos
20 mil millones de dólares el próximo
año y alberto fernández dice no no
tenemos dinero indicadores económicos
las acciones globales están al alza este
miércoles raúl a pesar de que los
inversionistas están nerviosos por la
reciente identificada variante del una
virus en asia las bolsas cerraron con
ligeras ganancias en europa el rebote es
incluso mayor con los principales
índices subiendo más del 1 por ciento a
media jornada para finalizar este primer
bloque económico que nos trae hoy como
cifra el día bueno es una cifra de
triste raúl de usted que hace si una
persona que trabaja cuando usted tiene
vih/sida pues nada una persona normal y
corriente solamente normal pues mire en
una encuesta de la organización
internacional del trabajo el 40 por
ciento dijo no estar de acuerdo con la
integración de personas con vih/sida en
su ámbito laboral y un 60 por ciento
apoya la obligatoriedad de pruebas de
diagnóstico en el trabajo este sondeo es
de 55 mil personas en medio centenar de
países como le parece que más no tiene
nada que ver con el desarrollo personal
y profesional de una persona para
daniela muchísimas gracias entonces por
toda la información nos vemos son más
adelante con más economía vamos ahora a
pasar a nuestro reportaje vamos